let's do a little thought experiment
imagine for a moment that you're a
subject in an experiment and they take
your arm and place it in a cast so that
it's locked at a 90° angle they keep you
like this for the course of several
weeks when it eventually comes off your
arm is quite different it's undergone
some significant changes of course you
would have lost muscle you haven't been
using it you haven't been training it
but the changes go deeper than that
because the very architecture of the
muscle will have changed that's because
your muscle has begun to adapt to its
new functional range shortening the very
length of the components that make up
the muscle the muscle fibers to use the
technical term you'll see a reduction in
the sarir in series meaning that there
are fewer contractile proteins arranged
end to end and of course this is going
to have big implications for us when it
comes to the way that we can move and
the force we can exert a first we might
not be able to move the joint much at
all due to stiffness but even once this
wears off our ability to exert Force
across that full range of motion will be
significantly diminished now at first
this might sound a bit like body horror
having your muscles forcibly changed
against your will but what if I told you
that something like that is likely
happening to you right now and it
happens all the
time so there are studies like this
looking at cases of individuals who've
had their joints immobilized for
whatever reason fun story this actually
specifically happened to me I had my arm
and an elbow cast for actually several
months due to some complications and my
arm was so weak I couldn't even lift it
up on its own I had to use my other arm
to lift that withered arm but if you sit
in the same hunched posture every single
day several muscles in your body are
continuously being shortened they're
being immobilized in just the same way
and your body will adapt in just the
same way and you're going to lose not
only range of motion but also forc
production it's sobering to think that
our productivity focused Lifestyles have
physically altered our bodies to become
more efficient work machines and less
efficient at self-expression and
movement now you might think this isn't
a problem you can just counteract it
with Mobility stretches or with regular
training but the truth is that these
types of training aren't enough to undo
this specific effect if you train with
heavy weights in the gym you can make
your muscles bigger but you're not going
to lengthen those fases those muscle
fibers in the same way that you would do
with specific other forms of training
but of course there's good news the
reason I'm making this video is that
there is a strategy you can use in order
to counteract this effect you can use
this strategy to Target muscles that
have been shortened by poor posture and
thereby regain your normal muscle length
and power but furthermore you can use
this strategy across the board in order
to unlock your untapped athletic
potential to improve your running speed
your jumping height by giving you more
ability to use your muscles across their
full functional
range now keep in mind that what we're
not talking about here is the muscles
visibly shortening end to end this isn't
going to make you taller or make your
arms look longer because the actual
length of your muscle belly is more to
do with your tendons and your insertions
that said it might have some effect on
the resting length of the muscle because
this is connected to the Optimum length
of the muscle which we're going to talk
about in a moment and it follows that
longer fibers would enjoy a slightly
lengthier resting state but I haven't
been able to find research that
explicitly makes this connection so
we're going to just put that to one side
for now we're talking about
architectural changes within the muscle
the way that the contractile proteins
are actually arranged within the muscle
fibers so as mentioned what we're
talking about here are sares and Series
so saram are the smallest contractile
unit of muscle they're comprised of
actin and myosin which are proteins that
move on top of each other in order to
collapse the sarir and as your sarir
contract when enough of them contract it
causes the muscle fiber as a whole to
contract and when enough of those
contract then the muscle shortens and
that's high produce Force you can't
increase the number of muscle fibers you
have but by increasing the number of
sarum ears you can make them thicker and
larger and when you do this enough it
makes the whole muscle appear bigger but
it might then be a bit reductive to talk
about hypertrophy making the muscles
bigger a much more interesting question
is bigger how are the muscle fibers
getting thicker or are they getting
longer your body is actually smart
enough to adapt to the very specific
demands placed on it in the case of
Muscle changes this occurs via meano
transduction signaling processes that
are triggered by specific forces acting
upon the muscles in this case leading to
alter gene expression changing the
physical makeup of the muscle way to
hold a dumbbell at a 90° angle for long
enough you'd expect this to send some
kind of signal to the body to adapt
likewise though if you're holding a
position where you're hunched forwards
your body is going to adapt to that and
when we're sitting many of us sit with
our shoulders hunched forwards our neck
pitched forwards our arms stretched out
in front of us to reach the keyboard
wrist at an awkward angle to operate the
mouse pelvis tilted back rounded and
hips flexed with our knees up nearer to
our chest over time this causes many of
those muscles to become shorter the hip
flexes the PEC and this has the exact
same effect as if we were to seal them
in a cast causing those muscle fibers to
become physically shorter so how do we
send that strong signal to make them
longer again well we could spend an
equal amount of time with those same
muscles in a lengthened position but I
mean you're not going to get into the
crab pose and just hold it for 8 hours a
day so what is this secret technique to
lengthen the muscle fibers well we can
use something called Ecentric training
many of you will already be familiar
with eccentric training Ecentric
training basically means the length
lening portion of any movement so
instead of emphasizing the part where
you lift the weight up in a curl you're
going to emphasize the part where you
lower it slowly back down so you're
going to lower it as slowly as possible
against that resistance or jump up to a
pull-up bar and then really slowly allow
yourself to lower back down here you're
accentuating The Eccentric portion of
the movement usually this means that
you're lowering the weight or yourself
down in a controlled manner but not
always so it's not really about the
direction the movement but whether the
target muscle is shortening which is a
concentric contraction or lengthening
which is an Ecentric contraction or
eccentric and as it would happen this
kind of training can increase sares in
series good news so in theory then we
could use Ecentric training to undo some
of the damage caused by poor posture now
this won't necessarily fix your posture
because your posture is the result of
multiple different factors such as habit
for example what your preferred resting
length of the muscle is and your
preferred resting tone and like I said
said we haven't found a direct
connection between Saruman series and
resting length of the muscle but with
that said we might be able to use
excentric training to undo some of the
negative effects that your posture could
have had on your performance so for
example if you've got shortened pecs you
could use very slow eccentric flies in
order to undo some of that damage and to
regain the strength at the end ranges of
motion flies might work particularly
well as there's also an element of a
weighted stretch involved now while
weighted stretching has not been
definitively shown to increase circum is
in Series in a preferential manner it is
nevertheless a good way to get more bang
for your buck because you're also
getting a stretch in there this could
have beneficial impact for throwers or
for martial artists throwing a punch
because they can generate more power at
that most stretched position at the
amortization phase of the movement which
is exactly what we want so just to
describe this a little bit better if you
were to try and throw a ball as far as
possible you'd start by rotating your
shoulder backwards and bringing the
opposite hip forwards so what you're
doing here essentially is winding up the
body you're twisting this way to stretch
the muscles that you're going to use
loading them so that you can then exert
the maximum Force across the maximum
distance this also helps you to engage
as much muscle mass as possible by using
the CUPE effect but if you were to
stretch back too far rotate back too far
you'd actually now lose power because
the muscle would now be too stretched
it's gone beyond the optimum muscle
length but by using eccentric training
we can increase the optimum muscle
length meaning you could rotate back
further meaning you could exert even
more force and throw the ball even
further and there are studies showing
directly that eccentric training will
improve your Mobility giving you greater
range of motion but also your Force
output at a greater range of motion and
these studies generally conclude that
this has great implications for sports
training in general so for example one
study found that fences could improve
their lunge length by training
eccentrically with their hamstrings
others have shown that it can
potentially transfer to Greater running
speed because your glute is in a
stretched position as it exerts force on
the ground when you're running the same
thing goes from jumping from a standing
position what we're doing here is
changing the optimum muscle length so
the optimum muscle length refers to the
length at which the muscle can exert the
most Force so one of the reasons that we
always have a little bit of tension in
our muscles called our muscle tone is
because we need a little bit of tension
in order to exert maximum Force when we
want it so for example if you want to
jump as high as possible going to dip
down into a squat but you're not going
to dip all the way so your ass touches
the grass because then it's much harder
to get out of that position and jump up
higher with eccentric training the
optimum muscle length is actually
extended meaning that you have more
muscle to play with when it comes to
exerting Force if your maximum power
starts at a greater stretch then you
have a greater distance at which to
generate power and momentum and this is
how we can tap into that greater
athletic potential that I was talking
about you know if the joint is already
half bent before or you can exert
maximum Force then you don't have much
space to exert that Force across and so
you're limiting the amount of force you
can produce eccentric training has a ton
of other benefits as well it can
actually increase your maximum speed of
contraction so it's definitely something
you want to start playing around with
and of course this has also been shown
to reduce injury risk because you're
gaining more strength and thus more
control with your muscles in those more
vulnerable lengthened positions so to
incorporate these ideas into our
training what we might want to do is
look at the muscles that may have become
shorter from our lifestyles from our
regular postures and then use this
training to counteract that like I say
you can use deep flies to counteract
short pecs likewise you might use some
kind of excentric training for your hip
flexors to gain more power and
explosiveness there to lift your legs up
faster when you're running and of course
if we're training for athleticism we
want to Target specific muscle groups
here as well for example the glutes if
we want to exert more Force when running
or for example we want to deliver more
power when rotating at the hips if we're
a martial artist something else to keep
in mind though is that eccentric
training does does create extra muscle
damage this is the good kind that leads
to hypertrophy but if you're going to be
using a lot of this kind of training
then you also need longer recovery times
so make sure to program that in at the
same time you might want to look at your
lifestyle and start addressing some of
the ways in which you could be
negatively impacting on your muscle
fiber length so for example improving
your posture at work that really just
means moving a lot because as they say
your next posture is your best posture
at the same time they might want to look
at other things you do regularly so for
example if you currently wear
traditional Footwear with a heel this is
going to do a number on your carves
regular viewers probably already know
where I'm going with this that's why I'm
happy to introduce today's sponsor Vivo
Barefoot so Vivo Barefoot make barefoot
shoes minimal shoes meaning they're
designed to allow you to move in a more
natural way to get out of your body's
way essentially there's no heel to toe
drop for example meaning your foot is
flat on the floor allowing it to move as
it supposed to putting your calf back in
its regular position at the same time
this means your toes aren't bent up
upwards against the floor at the same
time the wider toe Box means your toes
can spay out as they're supposed to in
general you're no longer immobilizing
the muscles in your feet and your lower
legs Vivo Barefoot make my favorite
barefoot shoes they are fantastically
wellmade they last forever and they're
extremely comfortable moreover they look
really cool and there's such a wide
variety you can find a Barefoot shoe for
like any situation whether you're going
hiking whether you're going into the
office whether you're going shopping or
whether you're going to the gym I
recently made a video on training like
Solid Snake which you guys should check
out because it's one of my best videos
and not that many people watched it I
actually wore a pair of Vivo Barefoot
there that were designed to look more
like boots and they perfectly fit the
role and right now because it's the end
of the year VI be are actually offering
an even bigger discount than usual for
viewers of my channel if you use code
bioner 20 you can get 20% off of a pair
of Vios this discount is exclusive to my
channel and it's only available till the
end of the year so if you want to get in
on that then head to the link in the
description down below it's after the
new year then you can use my regular
discount code that's the Bion 15 for 15%
off a huge thank you to Vivo Barefoot
who've been fantastic to work with this
year so what do you think guys do you
use eccentric training did you know that
it could change the length of your
muscle fibers let me know in the
comments down below let me know any
other tips that you found and thanks a
ton for watching this one thanks as well
for all of your support this year I
don't know exactly what time this is
going to be going up what day so merry
Christmas happy holidays whatever you
celebrate happy New Year and I hope you
have a fantastic 202 4 see you then and
bye for now